so are you a morning person not at all
okay so when does your day start I said
before that I do not believe in mornings
because I've never seen one I my day
actually you know it's like 10 o'clock
when I'm drinking my first cup of coffee
going come on love and then probably in
like the noon to 2:00 is when I start to
do the writing thing I my thing is when
I'm I try to write five pages a day five
good pages a day and some days those are
short days because if you just comes
right out and other days it's like I'm
taking a pair of pliers and pulling the
words out one by one from my brain and
you know sometimes they're long days one
of my rules is not to reward myself for
failure and it that means that if if I
don't make my five pages I don't get to
eat ice cream I don't get my dessert
you know I that's those are those are
rewards I don't go see a movie if I
don't get my five pages done if I do my
old route in the valley used to leave me
at a coffee Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf
that's right across from the AMC Burbank
and so if I finish my five pages I would
walk across the street and see a movie
as my reward if I didn't do my five
pages I'd go home and you know I think
sometimes people this is this is a weird
writer thing is we get depressed if we
fail and then when we get depressed we
go for comfort food I'm just gonna eat a
gallon of ice cream and that's the wrong
message to send to yourself plus eating
a gallon of ice cream probably isn't
good for you but you know the the thing
is like if you fail to me if I fail to
make my five pages
I don't reward myself when I was working
in the warehouse my thing was one page a
day and if I write if you write one page
a day every day
that's three spec scripts by the end of
the year so I when people say I've been
working on this script for the past five
years I go what are you doing writing
five words a day you know what is the
you know
you need to put in a little more effort
there the other thing is when you're
writing professionally there are
deadlines and some of them are crazy so
you have to be prepared to be able to
write against the clock but if you're
not on a deadline it sounds like you're
you're a pretty good manager yeah yeah
you have to be that's the thing if
you're your own boss you have to be you
can be the nice boss but you also have
to be the mean boss you have to be the
boss that when you're slacking off
cracks the whip and says you've got to
get back to work and people this is the
the fantasy that writers have or you
know that non writers have about writing
is that once I've quit my day job I
never have to deal with idiot bosses
producers I never have to you know I can
yeah I can sleep as late as I want which
is fine as long as you get the work done
and I never have to actually like punch
a time clock or anything like that and
you now have to punch your own time
clock you've got to manage your day so
that you get work done because if you
don't get the work done you're gonna end
up at the end of your time going I don't
have a script to go out and the rents
due you know I've got I've got to make
some sale I've got to do something I've
got a shake-up I'll usually expect
scripts shake up the world so you get
meetings and you know if you've got a
you got to get scripts done you've got
to be the mean boss
you